IMAX is the most immersive way to see a
movie
to see those images at that scale with
that kind of sound I mean obviously I
would love it if everyone could see it
that way
[Music]
we worked really hard visually designing
the movie so that there were a vast
array of looks and color schemes and
feeling of different sequences and some
more visual and some more oral the sound
river is the resistance base where it's
kijima there's so many different planets
the fight sequences those emotional
moments the music you want to go see in
the best way possible
the action is over-the-top one of my
favorite sequences in the movie is when
we were out in the deserts of persona
the gang were on something we call the
speeder and it was a wonderful exciting
and mechanical rig to the acting on and
now to see it on screen really action
and the drama is is huge and boy does it
give you energy and power in the first
20 minutes you are just racing around I
cannot believe what it's going to be
like on IMAX huge
[Music]
it's everything that you want out of a
Star Wars movie it's it's thrilling it's
hopeful it's exciting it's emotional are
you doing there a3 bill taking one last
look sir
but my friends it's something that's
bigger than anything I've ever been a
part of this chapter closing that's what
makes it be sweet but if iconic and
special the thousand generations live in
you now Star Wars is a part of cinema
history I mean it's such an important
part of our film fabric and to have an
opportunity to close out a part of this
huge Star Wars history on IMAX would be
so incredible the force will be with you
boys
[Music]
you